okay so this is like just an extra
little bonus thing we're doing before we
start this week's adventure time view
logs uh when we reviewed holly-jolly
secrets right part two I was talking
about how great I love the episode how
wonderful it was and we both really
really enjoyed it and there was one
segment where I interpreted Finn
enjoying this as something else
oror Finn's interpretation this is
something else people freaked the fuck
out over this and they just went insane
and I usually try not to read the
comments cuz I don't want stuff given
away but like people were emailing me
like you know oh people want you dead
and it was fine because the I want say
like a day after I just coincidentally
had nostalgia critic editorial called
when does it movie just a movie which is
a show just to show what comic books and
stuff like this and a few people
actually did email me saying like you
know after I saw an account felt like a
dick and just want to say sorry it's
also to the people did that you know
just thank you that was very nicely the
same and stuff like that but okay just I
think I just think this is really really
important to say it's really important
to get out there if there is anyone who
will call bullshit on my opinion it's me
okay like I will be the first to say my
opinion doesn't mean anything it's bull
crap like anyone's opinion it's not fact
it's not any of that stuff it's
something that's supposed to be enjoyed
and challenging and give you a different
point of view and have fun with it's not
supposed to it's not supposed to carry
this much anger and this much emotion
it's really not and let me point this
way if if you disagree great if you
agree great that's the blame and that's
the plan but stalking cuz we disagreed
on it you know I'm sure you had your
point of view I have mine were just like
whatever you know I mean there's like
he's not a Disney fan
I love Disney but I'm not gonna look at
him like he's like the world's biggest
animal or something like that I look at
him as the world's biggest a-hole for
other reasons I wish you would do the
same for me if you're not gonna like me
like me four reasons to not like a
person don't like me because I have a
different opinion on a TV show because
let me tell you something if this is the
kind of stuff that really hurts you like
actually gets you at your core you have
a lot of really tough stuff coming to
you in life and it's just gonna be made
much tougher by you not being able to
handle something as little as this and I
don't want you to go through that I
really don't
oh I I don't I really don't you know
because everybody every human being has
the right to be happy you have that
right every human being does use that
right you are entitled to that right
enjoy that right there's not gonna be a
shortage of things to come after you and
make you feel bad life is full of those
things and the amount of effort and
hatred that was being put into like some
of these comments no amount of effort or
hatred should be put into something like
this where what we should do with our
troops that should have that amount of
effort and anger how to get people going
to sleep at night hungry and starving to
have that not happen anymore that
deserves that amount of effort and anger
Finn and the ice King's glasses does not
deserve that amount of effort or anger
you have the right to be happy
use that right utilizing channel it be
happy
don't let stuff like this hurt you it's
not worth it you're worth more tell
yourself you are worth more just please
don't let stuff like this hurt you
that's all I got how about you you ever
thought about being like a motivational
speaker I could go to businesses and
you're like the guy that pumps everyone
up and goes we're gonna learn on him
back boxes boxes it's like it would be
really good at that I know what you
wanna know why I'll tell you exactly why
cuz I was there at one point when
somebody would disagree with me on a
movie I actually would turn this douse
your critic I know people are probably
way she does possess the massage brother
stuff strength is a character and it's
an exaggeration of you know my opinion
but I did use to kind of be like that
and I look back and I'm really
embarrassed by it when I think about the
people and like like a lot of the Disney
films you didn't like you man no no you
are evil you are the devil I came to
look at you like a like I used to take
that stuff really seriously and then
it's like as you know real life sets in
it's like oh this is the shit that
really matters this is the stuff I
should have been preparing myself for
instead of this garbage you know and
this stuff these things we watch are
supposed to be preparing us for these
things and instead we're getting angry
you know with them when it shouldn't
matter it's like we should be focusing
on the sort of stuff that does matter
and we should be happy about the things
that we do have rather than trying to
find things to get angry about I don't
think it's necessary see I can
understand what the people are saying
and how their uh how they're getting
upset some of them I don't understand
why they're getting a subset as they are
like that's going a bit far and all that
stuff like giving going way back when a
rebeccablack put out Friday it's people
sending her death threats it's a kid
making a song get over it yeah but first
stuff like Adventure Time and like I
don't know it's kind of one of those
things as an adult or as a kid or as a
teen
it's that fantasy place where you can go
and you feel comfortable and you feel
safe and you can get lost in your own
fantasy or you get lost in that fantasy
and you connect with these characters on
some level like people with Star Wars
people with Star Trek these are like fan
we're people they're just not they don't
just like the movie you don't that makes
me really this is a summers worth being
angry about now I have to go kill your
daughter I'm sorry that's fine if that's
worth killing over
I'll let you continue no it's just you
know people yeah like these fandoms
where these movies or TV shows or comic
books or whatever have taken on more
than just what they're there for
and I think something like Adventure
Time is one of those for people where I
think people were just more upset that
they finally had a very emotional scene
in an episode where it shows these
people are more human than we imagined
they are that there is actual tragedy
happening and I think a lot of people
were just kind of like more upset with
the whole fact of Doug how could you not
see that that this show is trying to
show you a little bit yeah and you're
concentrating on the glasses I agree
with you that these people are going a
bit - I'm only talking to the people
that are literally letting this hurt
them you know and getting so angry that
you know they feel like really to throw
this at you and it's it's just not worth
if you disagree that's fine and talked
about it and talked about why you think
it's this and why you think I'm wrong I
mean I honestly with what you said on
the adventure type thing uh you can be
right I mean neither of us throw away
there you go right well yes he made you
see more episodes but I mean as of now
that I know there's no official way of
like unless you ask the creator yeah you
know like what exactly the intention was
and even then you can still interpret it
different yes um but it's like yeah you
could be right and I could be totally
wrong and I say I get that's part of the
fun of the conversation so if you
disagree disagree you know I mean watch
my editorial I hit people i get my
simple lavatory about where's the movie
- some week because it just a lot of
people did actually have to say
great me and that's actually I was like
ah how I found out that this looked like
a big deal
a good example is when before when we're
talking and like I said I don't like the
Simpsons you know people would write in
and they won't be as aggressive that's
the whole holly jolly secrets thing but
they're like what's wrong with you how
can you not like it it's like there's
something wrong with me it's just that's
my taste
you know there's a bunch of people who
they adventuretime and I don't sit there
and look at them and go how dare you not
like it it's as you said it's an opinion
they're like assholes everyone's got one
and no I did not create that I don't
remember what movie I got that from but
I love that line opinions are like
assholes everyone's got one yeah I mean
so well point one for the oh yeah tell
us where its problem movies by the way
really quickly off subject again thank
you guys in the comments section for
they brought up the whole slow down
stuff yeah I saw that too I want to say
thank you you guys are always great with
that but yes the majority of people were
more uh more like the sad parents going
upset with you mr. Walker how could you
do that yeah even that honestly I think
it's a little bit more okay than yeah
yeah I mean just how like emotional and
angry they were giving it like I said
it's just it's not worth it oh yeah it's
just not worth it for all the Atlantis
that there's enough drama in the world
you don't need to go looking for it you
don't need to contribute don't go
looking for it it'll find you relax
it'll find you life kinda does that and
to look for stuff to get upset about
with this it's not worth it but is worth
discussing it is worth analyzing it is
we're disagreeing totally disagree and
talk about it I'm just saying to be you
know just for for your own sake to live
a happy good life I mean my thought is
that like you know it if you I live a
happy wise life you spend your life
getting this really complicated
intelligent mind to be all the more
appreciative for life's little blessings
I know that that's or how I see it so
you just just leave us don't fight yeah
talk don't argue yeah or a really maybe
who are you don't well don't let it
don't let it hurt one another there's no
point in legacy it's just there is stuff
that's worth for me each other over and
I know it sounds weird to say but there
are big issues it's like the world is
big and terrible things happen and that
is worth fighting for but this is
finding the ice King's glasses it's not
worth it it's not my disagree you think
it's worth actually getting in blows oh
I think I think we should pull out tanks
and all of that stuff do you have a tank
three in the backyard we need to play
like combat no Terry style its current
it's totally worth it I'm gonna go play
with the tank stop